among the many new revelations the IG
report blasts former FBI director James
Comey for how he handled the Hillary
Clinton email probe saying he broke
protocol the White House is responding
to stunning developments the president
was briefed on the IG report earlier
today and it reaffirmed the president's
suspicions about commis conduct and the
political bias among some of the members
of the FBI members all right let's bring
in special report anchor Bret Baier Bret
I'm sure you have not read the entire
thing or you probably may know me trees
will kill Jesse and we're all printing
[Laughter]
what really jumps out it used so far
from what you've seen from the report
one the big loser James Comey this IG
really goes after the former FBI
director for his decision-making to the
other loser Peter struck and Lisa page
and those text messages that are that
surface more of them in this report the
biggest of which will be I'm sure graphs
thought upon by President Trump and his
supporters and that is seven words
that's that is an answer to a text from
Lisa Paige to Peter struck Trump's never
going to become president right right
and struck then responds no no he won't
we'll stop it well that in and of itself
even though we don't have the full
context of what they're talking about
they're just that in a vacuum will
create major fuel to to the issue of of
what was happening behind the scenes the
the other thing though to note is that
overall at 30,000 feet the IG says that
they couldn't document political bias
within the FBI on the decisions made
early in the Clinton email case it does
raise questions though about the bias
that they did find and how that affects
the case after July when the FBI
director Comey comes out with that bad
news statement yeah and it seems like
the report really tees up the next IG
report about the Russia investigation
lay off of these new page struck texts
let's take it around the table kimberly
guilfoyle alright so you know Brett I
think there was a lot of you know people
saying there's gonna be significant
evidence in here it's obviously quite
voluminous but in terms of the level of
discussion that preceded this do you
think that the takeaway what you're
hearing from behind the scenes is that
this was something that they over
promised under-delivered or how would
you characterize it yeah I think first
of all depending on your political point
of view you're just talking pure
politics you'll look at this and and
there'll be people who say oh it's a
nothing burger and there will be other
people who say it's really chock-full of
damning things I think what you'll hear
from the FBI director Chris Rae is that
this is a big problem within the FBI and
they're going to probably announce some
kind of actions that they're taking if
you look at trey Gowdy and what he put
out in this in this statement that he
put out he says he's alarmed angered and
deeply disappointed and goes on to
detail in pretty scathing terms what he
sees and he's a guy who's defended the
FBI even in the most recent Spygate
stuff well Juan Williams took a really
good day to take off and we have Marie
harf and his place let me take it away
hi Brett well Jim Comey already
responded in a New York Times op-ed
where he endorsed the I G's efforts but
said he disagreed with some of the
findings in it what do you think's next
for Jim Comey does he keep speaking out
does he go quiet is he investigated
further by DOJ what happens for him next
I bet you he kind of goes into the night
it's interesting that he's out of the
country at the time the IG report is
coming out he obviously made his rounds
on the media including on special report
he made the book tour he kind of laid
the groundwork for his defense and
obviously has this letter to the New
York Times but the stuff in here
suggests that you know he made some big
mistakes in the eyes of the inspector
general of the Justice Department and
and no matter if you look at it from a
Clinton perspective that that there are
folks who think he costs Hillary Clinton
the election or a trump perspective and
how he dealt with the president Trump
after the after the election
I mean he took it on the chin I mean
they said he committed serious
violations of FBI policy and processed
and then damaged the credibility of the
investigation and the institution itself
so pretty tough stuff coming out of the
IG report Danny well right in James
Comey statement in reaction to this
right away purse a tweet and then an
op-ed in The New York Times he says look
I respect the IG I think they did a
great work here reasonable people can
disagree so he's moving on now the
struts attorney he did put out a
statement as well but he didn't address
these text messages and I'm curious if
you think that that might happen and
then my other question is Michael
Horowitz the inspector general had a lot
of bipartisan support
lots of credibility across
administration's congressman Ratcliffe
said today that he has read the report
he's been briefed on it and he still
maintains confidence in Michael Horowitz
which I guess means that this next IG
report which is on the actual Clinton
emails themselves and that investigation
would at least have some credibility
yeah and I think these are questions
that I'm going to ask chairman Gowdy and
Goodlett and they'll be on in the next
hour on special report I think that
there is a lot here that tees up as
Jesse mentioned the next iteration of
the AG's efforts and the second text the
part that says no no he won't be
President we'll stop it that was just
released last in the past few days weeks
and the first part where the question is
asked will he be President was released
but the second part was not you know
that tells you something about
transparency and where this document
back-and-forth is going up with Capitol
Hill and an oversight I think to your
point people will look at this and
there'll be Republicans who look at it
and say it just didn't deliver and I
think others will look at it and say
there's a lot in here yet to be mined
okay now from the five's inspector
general yes Greg Gutfeld this is a
stunning read bread it's blowing my mind
hey I heard a rumor that the FBI is
gonna change their name to fw beef feds
with benefits is that true there was
there is a section yeah
report that deals specifically with that
about tickets from media organizations
and invites to golf outings and yes yes
I do have a serious question there was a
part there where we found out that Comey
used his private email to conduct I
think it was non classified business
which may be why he couldn't dam Hillary
for doing the same thing because it's
like mutually assured destruction
everybody's guilty of doing the same
thing could that be part of the reason
why he decided not to proceed further I
tell you what these you're trying to be
funny but these are really good nuggets
of the report that had not been kind of
put out there Comey is using a private
email even though it's unclassified to
deal with the email investigation of
Hillary Clinton and the IG says that's
not a good thing I've got the gutfeld
Diaries over here and I've been looking
through them frightening you're on page
70 nice job with the interview the other
day the president yeah and II will be
looking forward to 6:00 p.m. for another
great special report all right see you
guys
all right Kimberly like we talked about
some of these nuggets that are coming
out and it's gonna take probably another
24 hours to get all of them her emails
were penetrated by a foreign agent and
that we really didn't know because Comey
himself said it was possible that that
happened and now we learned that it
actually did happen and one of those
emails was considered secret which means
disclosure of that email reasonably
could be expected to cause serious
damage to the national security of the
United States yeah I did I think this is
significant because it much was made at
the time oh well it's possible but there
was no nailing it down but obviously
they knew and we're not honest about it
and essentially what I call that as a
cover-up like why if you knew that in
fact that they had been penetrated and
they'd have been red etc by or access by
a foreign agent that is significant it
is a security breach of the highest
order and something that is very
disconcerting for us for national
security but there you go
Hillary Clinton the rules of law do not
apply
to her or to mr. Comey birds of a
feather flocking together right another
weasel move by the director Murray some
of the nuggets that I'm really
interested deal with struck because they
keep coming we'll stop it meaning will
stop the Trump presidency when you pair
that with they need to protect the
country from Donald Trump and we need an
insurance policy in case he is elected
and now FBI agents are calling Trump
supporters at least five FBI
agents exchanging anti Trump Pro Hillary
text messages the IG says there was
willingness to take official action to
impact Trump's electoral prospects that
sounds pretty serious to me it does and
I think they demonstrated an incredibly
bad judgment but the IG also found that
there was no evidence that political
bias or improper motivation affected the
Hillary email investigation so what I've
always said is these people should not
have been doing this it was stupid it
looks bad and the IG actually found that
that it looked bad it called him to
question the investigations impartiality
but there's no evidence that their
personal views impacted it because
they're not dumb enough to leave the
paper trail you and a lot of folks on
the conservative side have been waiting
for this report and basically putting a
lot of faith in what comes out of it
they found very clearly I think since I
think we've been downplaying it he said
it was probably gonna be a Wow a big
hairball go ahead I think I think it's
important this is selective history fake
news I think that it's important that
they did not find evidence that a
political bias impacted the
investigation they also found that they
had no way no ability to prosecute
Hillary Clinton under the five statutes
they examined so I'm not an attorney but
the Department of Justice looked into
the question that that a lot of
Republicans and Trump supporters keep
bringing up and found in fact that they
did the right thing here that's actually
not sure what what the IG report says
Dana is that witnesses meaning
prosecutors at the DOJ are FBI
investigators didn't think that this
would be a prosecutable case it doesn't
mean the IG concluded that that was the
fact that just meant
some attorneys disagree well and to
further that I think one of the things
Comey did was so they the IG says
insubordinate their insubordination but
who did that really benefit right it
fitted Loretta Lynch who was the
Attorney General because he then took it
out of her hands for making a charging
decision that I'm sure President Obama
and Loretta Lynch did not want to do to
their nominee of course this gets me
back to the original point of how do we
even know any of this why have we spent
so much time and so much money on all of
this and it's goes back to Hillary
Clinton's decision yeah to subvert the
process to have her own email system to
have a private server and we are so that
was in 2015 we found him out is 2015
who's been 500 pages out of its why
doesn't she bring it back now she's what
you say what you might say is that at
least she uncovered this you know struck
and page email situation and their bias
against the president we never looking
backwards for a long time on the show we
I remember we said I was I don't know
when it was it's it would she was like
talking about gender and we kept it's
not about the female it's about the
email right that's what we kept saying I
a couple of points I would show this yes
it is like the white oh it's it also it
how amazing it must be to be Anthony
Weiner he might be one of the few people
who's happy he's in jail because not to
because the fact is if it wasn't for his
laptop and his lap Trump wouldn't have
been elected and guilty I mean he kept
we should be thanking Anthony Weiner
he kept Hillary out of office that's
really about him in Houma but I was
there they are
also it is amazing again this is more
evidence that Donald Trump can turn
people into emotional high school
freshman struck in page they were like
the characters in the David Bowie song
heroes you know they're up against the
wall they're fighting the other two men
they're - they're gonna stop Trump they
do anything they can
it was so deeply emotional for them they
were like they were like star-crossed
lovers in a in a romantic song I want
one final point starlets like a liberal
how exactly does I think it's weird
timing that the day that this report
comes out the the media gets a gift into
this state of New York so
Trump over the Trump foundation it's
incredibly well played and it's be a
coincidence no it's not it's it's it's
party and media working hand-in-hand and
it's it's and it's just to me just so
obvious and wrong it is and to go to
jail about Carlos danger they found that
they sat on these emails for I think a
month and Strock was behind those slow
walking those up to James Comey Me's
office yeah it's when you see this it's
really sad isn't it though you know we
read this and you become almost
desensitized but this is really
egregious you're talking about you know
the FBI that is you know held to the
highest regard in terms of justice and
supposed to be truth seeking in fact
finding without any ideological bent and
you see people here that were only
hell-bent on undermining the term
campaign and preventing a presidency you
see a candidate in Hillary Clinton that
completely just disregarded the law
destruction of evidence and really just
creating a situation that undermines a
confidence not only in our political
process and campaigns and elections but
in our highest investigatory agencies
and what you're seeing here is a
modified redacted report by Ron
Rosenstein who was allowed to do this
and he's actually in the middle of all
but so how is this you know coming at it
with clean hands we actually don't know
what all the evidence is because some of
it has been removed well and I think
some members of Congress are trying to
request the original drafts of the
documents before they were changed or
allowed to have been looked at by other
people